hey guys my name is Jesse does the tenth
of May today and here's the important
things that happened in games today
Okajima is well and truly back on our
radar revealing details about his next
project Kazuma told Japanese games
publication from mitsui that the project
may not seem remarkable when it's
announced but a short it's an amazing
game he explains while not to say it's
open world users who enjoyed today's
Triple A games in the division in
uncharted etc will be able to easily
enjoy it the genre is action he added
that the dev team are creating the plot
characters and game systems at the same
time the new project has been created in
partnership with Sony Kojima said that
while he received offers from all over
the world he opted for Sony because they
showed faith in him and they offer the
team and lot of freedom to no one's
great surprise but everyone's epic
disappointment Mass Effect Andromeda has
been officially delayed until early 2017
by where general manager Ehren flem
explained in a blog post as we've been
playing the game at the shittier
recently it's showing us that we're
taking the game in the right direction
but we also know we need the right
amount of time to make sure we deliver
everything the game can be and should be
it's also been confirmed that the game
will be showcased at the EA play
conference on sunday june twelfth
elsewhere in the blog post Flynn said
that the game's design pillars are
centered around providing players more
freedom new uncharted worlds to explore
and offering the next great Mass Effect
experience on current-gen consoles with
dices frostbite engine by way of the
pokemon company has released a new video
and a release date for Pokemon Sun and
Link the game is set to arrive on 3ds on
November 18 and the trailer shows off
the three starter Pokemon you'll be able
to choose from there's an adorable
little owl looking thing with a leaf
boat I called rowlett who is a flying
grass type a moody looking fire type cat
called Lytton and a water-type pokemon
who looks a lot like a seal called
Pope Leo are in a way the most fun to
say if that's something you're factoring
in in relays with news the National
Pokemon Trading Card Championship is
coming up and you can check it out on
twitch beginning may 14 let me know down
in that comment section which starter
Pokemon you'd pick for sun and moon you
can also do gamespot where we've got
stories on star wars battlefront sales
and to meet for Speed updates that is
everything I got to you today as always
do let me know what mattered to you and
I will see you again tomorrow